all right everybody we are live and
joining me is former google senior
software engineer turned guy who shared
his opinions turned guy who was fired
for those opinions
from google james damore welcome to the
reuben report thanks it's great to be
here i am uh i'm looking forward to this
to prove that we're doing this live we
were about to go live about a minute ago
and right before we started you said to
me
uh should the dog be in here should the
dog be in here my dog was was laying
here but we took the collar off but we
we let her go so i i appreciate that uh
you have had a crazy whirlwind of a
month and uh i mentioned to you when we
were in the green room that
i asked you what the exact day that you
thought all this went down you said
august 5th
which was right when i was going off the
grid so as i was getting my phone out of
hand when i was going to put it away and
disappear i saw your name i saw the
story and i was like man this is the
type of guy that i gotta talk to i
should be all about this story uh but
then i disappeared so i'm glad we're
doing this uh so let's say so let's
start with this first off how are you
just as a human being we're going to get
to your backstory we're going to get to
the the ideological echo chamber they
have right here but how are you as a
human being right now i'm doing okay i
mean i wish i had a job but
you know
it's not until you
don't have one that you realize the
benefits of you know having a job and
going to work every day
having a group of people that you hang
out with
it's nice
so you were fired do you know the exact
date
august 7 ish august 7th so this thing
ruminated and banged around for about
three or four days or so and then you
were fired
were you
absolutely shocked that you were fired
for writing
this 10-page manifesto that's the word
that i've seen do you ever what word
would you
uh prescribe to this document that i'm
holding here i've just been calling a
document
you just document yeah it's funny you
said to me before you said you know
uh like sort of something like i can't
believe i'm in this like
i'm just some nerd and i guess the way a
nerd would describe a document is just
by document but were you completely
shocked at what happened here yeah i
i never really thought that it would
explode like this i
i was just wanted to have a one-on-one
conversation with
the diversity programs and you know
really discuss the issues
but it never really came to that okay so
for the people that don't know what this
is about obviously we're going to get to
that but before anything else i thought
it would be important just to talk about
your biography a little bit just to to
prove you're a guy who knows what he's
talking about and you're a well-educated
guy and all that so can you just uh take
me through a little bit of your history
schooling types of jobs you had and what
your job was at google
so i went to university of illinois for
undergrad i was doing science like
biology physics chemistry
and then
i didn't really know what i wanted to do
so i
decided to graduate early and then just
work at mit for a year and that was a
lot of fun took some classes there
and then i decided to go to grad school
so i
went to systems biology which is like
mathematical biology at harvard
and that program was really great
but so i went there for about two years
it was the phd program and
but while i was there i got really into
algorithms and these little puzzle
things so i
did a
coding competition
and
google found out that i did well so they
actually just directly contacted me
said that oh yeah you should apply to
google
so i interned there and decided you know
google is a great place yeah it's you
know
probably the company that will change
the world
and
its benefits are great so i was like
okay this is a once in a lifetime chance
i'll just do it
and so i left the phd program to join
google yeah and this is just a couple
years ago obviously you're you're a
young guy so you mentioned some i mean
these are big name schools mit harvard
you are educate educated in biology and
you're working with algorithms all these
things google finds you after you do
this competition so
sort of to lay out how this whole thing
got written and why you did it
first you're working at google for a
while and then they started sending you
guys not just you but people to
diversity training is that correct right
okay so can you explain what diversity
training is
yeah it's
kind of complicated because there's
multiple different
programs but
uh it's often talking about
how you know we have 50 of people in the
population are women but at google we
only have 20 percent
and so they discuss all of the sexism
that's happening
and how that's holding back women in
general and
then they also have stuff about racism
and all these other unconscious biases
because you know we don't really see
anything like oh you're a woman
therefore you can't code there's never
these explicit forms of bias that we see
and so and we haven't really been able
to measure
x like actual bias at google so we just
assume that there's some sort of
low-level bias that's happening
and you know it's
always really impossible to measure but
so they these programs go over that they
go over microaggressions
and
white male privilege
and then discuss how we can
make the workplace better for women
and how we can get more women on our
teams basically yeah now uh you don't
have anything against women do you is
that something i need to know that james
damore thinks about women
before we go any further i definitely
like women i i had women on my team and
i you know i treated them well yeah i i
mean i discussed a lot of these issues
with them and they actually largely
agreed
and they helped me discuss you know okay
on average women are say more
cooperative and how can we change the
workplace so it's not just you know some
alpha male that
owns a project and gets promoted and
it's actually people working in teams
and all of them getting uh recognized
yeah so it's interesting to me because i
obviously have a small business here
most of my jobs in my life have been odd
jobs or doing stand-up things like that
i've never worked for a giant
corporation like google before and it's
funny because when you talk about
well 50 of the population is female and
google only has 20 percent it's almost
like well how is that an issue for the
average employee at google now the
microaggressions and that other stuff i
can see why if if you buy that that
stuff is legit if they're hr people buy
that stuff legit i can see why they'd
sit down with employees and talk about
that but to talk about the 50
of women in the population and we only
have 20 here isn't that something for hr
to deal with what does that have to do
with
bringing in software engineers and
talking to them about that
yeah i think google just has a long
history of you know the whole don't be
evil and you know we make a ton of money
through ads therefore we feel sort of
guilty and we have to help the world in
general so we do a lot of philanthropy
and
they're really big on being allies
for these groups
and just outreach in general yeah if it
makes you feel better they're not making
much money on us because they don't
monetize anything and i can't our video
i just told you before we started our
video from this morning from this
morning with phil defranco who has
almost 6 million subscribers who's one
of the first youtube creators
around was demonetized this morning it's
like so but i do want to talk to you a
little bit about the algorithm but let's
let's keep going with your story okay so
you go to these these meetings uh
obviously you're having a bit of an
ideological difference
in terms of what you think versus what
they're pushing on you uh they asked for
your feedback correct after these things
so can you tell me about that yes uh in
all of our meetings and programs in
general uh we're usually very open and
we asked for feedback in how we can
improve these
and so i i wrote this document because i
really wanted to put my thoughts down
and so i sent it to them and they looked
at it but they because it's a google doc
so i could actually see that they looked
at it and read through it but they just
never did anything and this happened
multiple times i went to multiple
programs and they just ignored it every
time yeah so to be clear when you say
program so you sent it to a they have
several diversity groups right so you
sent it to several different groups what
are some of the groups uh so one of them
was about unbiasing
and another was your journey towards
you know rethinking race
so those are
several of them that i went to
and yeah this is and we're just ignoring
yeah you saw that they were open but you
were just ignored so so just to be clear
you write this in response because they
want feedback that's actually nice to
hear that companies want feedback i keep
trying to get them on the phone with me
to discuss some of the problems that i'm
having with youtube that that seems to
be kind of difficult but you write this
in response which is sort of what
they're asking for they're asking for
your feedback now you are a
scary uh white male and you're tall
so that's got to be working against it
but you do you do what they want then
you submit this to several of these
diversity groups who ignore you then you
submitted it to one particular one and
that's where this really took off so so
which one was that yeah so after a month
of uh actually sending it to
individual people and some smaller email
lists and actually getting some good
feedback that wasn't you know this
emotional outrage i wait that's that's
interesting let's not jump past that so
first you're you are getting some
feedback within the company then people
are basically
basically okay
half the people would be just like yes i
agree totally
and then the other half would disagree
on certain points and they say oh are
you sure that this is happening and
especially
if you're progressive then you often
don't even see a progressive echo
chamber because you just see oh yeah
that's how things should be and what's
wrong with all of this
and oh are you sure that people would
actually be shamed for saying these
things
you know and because you think that that
system or that world view is so complete
or something it's hard for them to
imagine which is exactly what an echo
chamber is
and so that was all fine but then uh i
sent it to this one email list called
skeptics so i thought
you know skeptics would be rational and
they'd be able to
point out holes in my argument yeah
because honestly the whole time i was
just i want to be wrong because if i'm
right then there's something bad
happening right please tell me how i'm
wrong
and that's not really what the response
was it was just this is crap what are
you doing
and it eventually just exploded without
within the company yeah all right so to
be clear so the skeptic group which is
the group that should be skeptical of
all facts and opinions and all that you
send it to them but then how within that
so now you start getting some feedback
on it how within that group did this
then get to the larger world and that's
when all hell broke loose yeah uh so
some of the
people would start sending emails to say
my upper management and hr
demanding that i'd be fired or something
and so
hr and some of the higher level execs
started sending out mass emails saying
oh yes we know about this document don't
worry you know it's harmful don't look
at it this is not what google stands for
which obviously you know if you tell
someone that this is harmful they're
going to just look at it it's harmful
don't look at it that's what executives
were saying i mean that's it
and
also there were a ton of memes within
the company just talking about you know
how horrible this was
and just blasting me as a person
[Music]
now was there any retribution on those
people we'll get to you actually getting
fired and called into the office but you
as far as everything that i read in this
document which i did read you didn't
attack anyone personally you go out of
your way not to stereotype people can
argue with you know your conclusions or
all that but you were being attacked
personally by people then within the
company was there any retribution from
the on to those people no not that i
know of there was even someone that
emailed directly saying you are a
terrible person you're a misogynist i'm
going to like hunt you down
until
you're fired or i'm fired
like send this to hr i don't care which
means that maybe he knows that hr isn't
really going to do anything yeah
and so i sent it to hr but so you didn't
send hr did they even respond they said
oh yeah work from home
but i told you to work from home yeah so
i just i think it's so important to
repeat some of this stuff you wrote this
in response to being taken to a place
where they wanted your feedback now they
happen to not like your feedback okay
then you were being threatened in a way
by other employees and being attacked
online with the memes and all that stuff
again while you're still an employee
there and hr tells you to work from home
yeah
and you have no evidence that they
contacted this person at all
i i honestly don't know and i mean there
were many people that started attacking
me
and it was mostly public attacks because
you know most people aren't really
courageous enough to send me an email
like that right and they just want to
show other people oh look how great i am
i
got offended by this and let's all band
together and punch nazis yeah yeah yes
right uh virtue signaling right yeah the
industry term for that okay so then
now you're b you are being attacked
personally you're being told by hr to
stay home
now did you get a call or an email how
did you end up in an office where they
said
you're out of here buddy
uh yeah so i
they eventually just called me monday
night and
said
james uh you've been terminated for
perpetuating gender stereotypes
and then you know i tried to discuss it
with them but they didn't have any of
that they did this on the phone yeah
they didn't even have you come into the
office and tell you face to face and
they were probably afraid that i would
just you know have some outbursts or
something well you seem very violent and
scary i mean i've never seen a more
soft-spoken you know
slim
you know you don't strike me as someone
that's going to hurt anybody but even i
mean the sort of cowardice of that is is
actually kind of incredible
so okay so then you get fired now this
is after it had gone public obviously so
the stories were all over the place at
this point um
did you try to plead your case i mean
did you say this is crazy i was just
doing actually the same thing that
you're asking everyone else to do you
just don't happen to like my opinions
yeah i tried to
but
obviously it didn't have any effect yeah
um
is there a legal issue there that you
know of i'm assuming every lawyer and
their cousin is out to talk to you these
days about uh
lawsuits and all that so i
even before they fired me i made a claim
to the national labor relations board
because what this is is i was making
concerted
effort with multiple other employees
that agreed with me to improve our
working conditions so you know i pointed
out multiple ways in which there was
harassment in the workplace and that
there was illegal uh discrimination in
our hiring practices yeah can you give
me an example of that of the legal
discrimination yeah yeah so
as far as i know and according to our
internal policies you can't use
someone's protected status so their age
race or gender
uh when you're determining hiring or
other employment critical situations
so
and but we do
in these you know we treat different
candidates differently and then if
someone is going up for promotion
they may be treated differently so
there's a lot of small things that we're
doing they may be treated differently in
a positive way if they're one of those
protected it's just worth actually
saying the full sentence because i think
people get people so confused by what's
going on these days that everything is
upside down yeah um
so okay so you contact them and then
where are you at in terms of any legal
stuff right now as much as you can tell
me uh yeah so we've filed the claim
and so they're investigating right now
and we are also looking for other
googlers that have had similar treatment
and we've gotten multiple responses for
that
so there have been multiple cases in the
past where say someone and like i'm of
course for gay rights but someone just
didn't want to go to gay pride parade
and they got fired for that it's like
that's a little too that's literally
true yeah
so someone at google just said i don't
want to go to the gay pride parade yeah
and they got fired for that
at least according to them we have to
look into it more but
and there have been multiple cases like
that where if you don't
agree with the progressive ideology
then
you're then you're discriminating
against and there's
you could also be totally pro gay and
just not want to go to a parade yeah
i'm not a huge parade guy myself you're
a big parade guy i i enjoyed the gay
pride parade in san francisco but
i i can definitely tell it's not for
everyone right right that's a bit of a
sidebar there um all right so so all of
this happens and again the reason i
started with how are you as a person is
that i know you know i can't compare
some of the things that i've gone
through over the last couple years with
what you've gone through because you you
were hit with a a landslide i've sort of
had a more like
slow evolution into craziness dealing
with the media and craziness but i know
what it's like when people write
terrible things about you and deeply
dishonest things and call me a nazi or
alt-right or
you know just all that crap right yeah
so suddenly you're a private citizen
from everything i can tell a pretty
decent guy and now the media
there's blood
what was that like for you because i
think that also is a lot of you know i
talk about the culture of fear right now
of why peop so many people email me and
they say well i'm afraid to say this or
i'm afraid to post your video on
facebook or any of this stuff and i
think it's because everyone fears this
retribution yeah so as someone that has
gone through it in a very high profile
way but you're still here you're still
here and even though you said to me
before you don't know what you want to
do next you don't know if you want to be
a public person next or a voice for any
of this but you made it to the other
side you're alive right now and you're
okay and you're smiling so
what can you say about that yeah i think
i realized that it was sort of do or die
and because if i didn't say anything and
if i didn't defend myself then
the media would just keep pounding on oh
this bigoted guy
said the sexist stuff
and you know i talked to jordan peterson
uh very early on and he told me yeah
just
you know talk to the media because once
they see that you're just a normal
person
and you're not
some crazy aggressive
woman hater then you know your case will
just get better yeah your public image
at least do you sense that that has
worked because you've done some stuff so
you did jordan peterson you did joe
rogan yesterday uh you got some
mainstream yeah stuff right
it's helped i mean unfortunately
it's
often either the center or the right
will interview me and i've tried to get
long-form interviews on the left and
just no one is biting yeah so
and so people will just
complain and say oh yeah i'm just
pandering to the right
it's a no-win situation you know it's
incredible to me how much i see this
story repeated and repeated so brett
weinstein who i
know you're familiar with he was only
asked to go on fox news tucker asked him
to go on i'm going on tucker tonight i'm
just saying it now for the first time to
discuss everything that's going on with
youtube and i get invited on tucker and
greg gutfeld and a bunch of other things
on fox nobody invites me from msnbc i
can't bash the door down much much like
you can so you tried you didn't try to
get on other left-leaning outlets i've
given interviews to cnn and bloomberg
business insider and you know they were
pretty hostile interviews but
i mean at least i did do them but it was
often you know i would do an hour long
interview and then they would cut it
down to five minutes of the worst
possible stuff i mean i still don't
think i
i it was bad but did you have anyone
helping you with media sensitivity
training or anything because like right
here i mean i i know you're aware of the
show and who i am and all that and i
don't have an agenda i truly want to
hear your story and that's it but that
when you go on these shows i know for
for me if i've learned anything is that
i would never do a show at this point
that's not live because i know the way
these people
act and behave
did you have any training or did you
hold counsel with anyone you you just
really just went out there and did it
yeah i i'm usually a pretty independent
person so i don't like asking for help
really
so i just did it
learning it as i go yeah so then i saw
on twitter that you were happy to take
these interviews and you did interviews
with people all over the place you were
on stefan moylandew now i've done his
show a couple of times i've never had
him here i've enjoyed the conversations
that i've had with him i get a lot of
hate for even talking to the guy
but then suddenly after that and you
were a member of the evil scary alt
right
so i also saw you tweet out that you are
not part of the alt-right or that you
you've said publicly you're not part of
the alt-right how does that even fit
into this because i think that's an
interesting thing this now catch-all
phrase of alt-right is becoming really
bizarre i mean i think it's just another
one of those labels that the media has
put on anyone that they disagree with
you know they were calling jordan
peterson all right they were calling
just everyone alt-right and
you know when you look at it and you
look at the definition like and it's
actually white nationalist or white
supremacist
you can see that no one
like very few people are actually white
supremacists but they're just using this
broad brush to
really label it's too many people yeah
and they're almost making the tent
bigger because every time they call you
all right or they call me all right or
jordan peterson well all these people
who who like what we think about things
they're going wait a minute that's what
the all-right is then it must be pretty
decent you know what i mean if damore
and peterson are in there and these guys
aren't bigots or racists or any of these
other things um but you you
now say that you are not part of the
alt-right or or any of that kind of
stuff were you shocked at eve so did any
of this shock you that that's what i
think is most interesting here is like
you obviously have seen all this like
it's pretty clear to me but did you as
someone that was going through it
did it shock you it definitely shocked
me i mean i knew at least some of the
lower level you know political bias can
shape how we view the world but i never
knew that it was this
widespread and the media portrayal was
so inaccurate
and you know i'm not necessarily a fan
of trump but i can see what he's saying
about you know cnn being fake news
because every one of their articles
about me would just be this horrible
stuff and
people i it was really nice to see that
all the comments were you know cnn this
is fake news did you actually read it
some people are fighting back right and
then i'm sure they're deleting those
comments i even saw something when i was
doing a little research um a few people
sent me something that you you mentioned
me in a in a reddit ama that you did so
i quickly googled both our names and
then it came up i think i can't swear to
it i think it was a think progress
article basically implying you're all
right and then they quoted me
obviously it wasn't talking about you
something from months ago making it seem
like i was part of that too and it's
like you're all liars and the more you
lie
the more you're just putting water on
gremlins and you're spreading the the
very thing that you fear most which i
guess is probably good for people like
us but it's it's a little annoying so
let me ask you this
i have your scary document here
by the way i flipped through this many
times i didn't even get a paper cut so
we're not we're not dealing with that
much here what would you say is the most
controversial thing that you wrote in
here is there is there one piece of this
thing
that you could go well i guess maybe
that's the one or maybe i said this
wrong or or what's the thing that people
were most sensitive to
so
me
uh saying neuroticism which is just a
personality trait and that's the
official term
that was a mistake maybe because a lot
of people were like oh he said women are
neurotic and that has a ton of negative
connotations
and then
uh yeah just the whole
of biology you know ever
whenever you mention biology that's
controversial when it comes to
differences between people okay so i'm
glad you mentioned that because i think
this might be the most important
important part of anything we're going
to discuss right now and if people are
listening to this i think this may be
the key thing of all this
it seems to me that the social justice
movement and this hierarchy of
oppression of the oppression olympics
and the virtue signaling
it seems like it is in direct conflict
with biology which is why they've been
so against richard dawkins a biologist
it's why they've thrown brett weinstein
a biologist under the bus it's why
they've attacked you someone who has
studied biology under the bus
it seems to me that because biology has
nothing to do with what they're talking
about they're talking about this sort of
amorphous
thing of victimhood as virtue but that's
not how biology works it's not how
evolution works or anything else
that it was it had to get here
do you think that's a fair statement
yeah i mean there are some biological
truths that you can't just
paint with oh this is just oppression
this is society
like constructed oppression
and you know it's really hard to just
keep denying some things yeah so what
would be an example of that of a simple
biological truth that would be against
uh i mean at least you know according to
this uh it's just the link between
prenatal testosterone and
some masculine-like behaviors
and so you know we've know that
testosterone does affect behavior and
you know if you ask someone that
transitions you know as transgender then
they'll also tell you that yes taking
this hormone treatment right it did
change me in some ways
and you know it's not good or bad it's
just
different right and if we were all the
same wouldn't there be then truly an
equal amount of women in the nba as men
i mean you wouldn't need the wnba right
like even if women if let's say women
i mean i have no idea but let's say
women love basketball as much as men do
i suspect generally speaking men like it
more i'm probably getting in some
trouble there i don't know what the
exact
study has shown on men and women in
basketball but why would you have i mean
there's obviously biological differences
otherwise you would have women doing 360
dunks yeah you know like lebron james
yeah i mean physicalness like and height
is definitely
something that's well known and not that
controversial yeah and i i feel like if
a woman wanted to join the nba they
should be able to sure but if a woman
has the skills that you can play in the
nba if the nba had a rule and said women
cannot play in this league
i would have a problem with that
actually you know i believe any you know
it's equal opportunity they have their
own league which is sort of separate but
equal but also nobody watches because
it's not it's simply not as good as the
nba man
i'm digging in it for those people but i
don't i don't really care what they
think um
so
the biology piece though
how do you as someone that cares about
this
how do you navigate that i mean when
you've seen people like dawkins and and
weinstein treated the way they're
treated how does this conversation get
cleaned up a little bit if guys like
that have so much trouble navigating or
will be kicked out by those voices on
the left
yeah it's really hard you have to just
find someone that's reasonable and have
a one-on-one discussion because
if you
just have this you know huge public
thing
then there's inevitably going to be
someone calling you some bigot or racist
and yeah
i i still don't really know how to
navigate the waters
i'm maybe not the best to ask yeah well
you seem like you're doing a fine job i
mean you're willing to to be part of
this fight you know we don't kind of we
don't always get the heroes we ask for
we get people that that are suddenly you
know either brave enough to write this
and again you weren't trying you
that's the irony here is i think a
certain amount of people will will look
at you or watch this and think oh you
know he just wanted to say something
controversial and get in profit from it
somehow or or get in the news or do
these shows or whatever it is
when in fact you did everything possible
to play by the rules that they had set
up to have your your voice heard
yeah i definitely never meant to for
this to become huge and it was never my
intention to
you know make it so big that i got on
this show although you know it's
obviously great to be here so uh i know
it was all to get on the rubik
um i'm curious what about what about
women either at google
or just that you've heard from on email
or social media or anything else that
are agreeing with you are you getting an
interesting amount of support from women
yeah i'm definitely getting a decent
amount of support from women and i think
the support is generally just based on
your political orientation so
libertarians and conservatives are much
more likely to agree with my document
than a progressive is
and it depends sort of just how
libertarian sort of you are right so
you're saying women are allowed to be
libertarian and conservative they don't
just have to be progressive right
there are controversial statements fewer
women that are libertarian though
for maybe similar reasons so that's kind
of interesting so there are so that's a
fact is that there are less women that
are libertarian because they might play
into some of these
causes so
i i don't know
but
the ratio is about the same 20 to 80. so
80 percent of libertarians are about uh
women
and it's
just the personality type of highly
logical
is
uh more
representative and that's the
personality type of libertarians and you
know very individualistic rather than a
more collective
personality now people are going to hear
that and that's j so this is so
interesting because it does get to the
heart of so many things we talk about
here and what ben shapiro says facts
don't care about your feelings you've
said a couple things right there that
they
they feel wrong in a way like there's
some what do you mean how could that be
but but the evidence
that doesn't mean things can't change
and that we all can't evolve differently
and all that but the evidence the facts
in this case
uh basically support what you're talking
about here yeah and i mean i don't feel
like people would necessarily say that
being libertarian is better than being
progressive or conservative and i guess
it depends where you are i i think a lot
of progressives that would find defense
with this think that being progressive
is good so
and they honestly think that
conservatives are evil so
yeah it's they're happy to be like how
they are yeah um
okay so now you've done a bunch of these
shows you've gotten your story out there
you've sort of been through the storm
already um it sounds like you don't know
exactly what you want to do next have
you been presented with any interesting
opportunities
uh i mean there's definitely i've talked
to random ceos that
were supportive but obviously many of
them didn't want to be publicly uh known
that they supported me so does that show
that we've sort of lost the war in a way
like we're like we're winning
interesting battles a guy like you who
you know nobody outside of your world
knew a month ago
you're you're now known and you're
gaining traction all that so i see that
as a win a battle a win of a battle but
in the war sense that all these ceos of
companies that they might want to work
with you might having nothing to do with
this they might just go man this guy's
got a great resume i want to work with
this guy he's a free agent right now uh
but even that that they they just might
be cowed because they don't want to deal
with it
yeah and
part of this uh
lawsuit is potentially trying to push it
the other way because so much of their
their concern is that they're being
attacked so much by these social justice
activists
and so if they
ever
go
more to
a more rational side on these topics
then they'll just be attacked but you
know if there's ever
you know
a lawsuit that says hey
you know you can't be
you can't discriminate against
conservatives
and
you know you can't be just some extreme
left and discriminate and do whatever
you want then
maybe they'll finally see the light i
don't know yeah but you know if there's
only one side happening then they'll
just become more extreme right and it's
so interesting to me because as you said
there were several different diversity
groups now i suspect but please correct
me if i'm wrong if there was a group of
pro-life people at google
would they be allowed to form a group do
you think
or how would that group be treated it's
i'm not sure that they would be able to
make a group i think some people would
say oh yeah that makes people
uncomfortable don't do this right now
you obviously would be able to create a
pro-choice group right i suspect there
would be no right that's that's in line
with leftism and progressivism but the
difference between pro-choice and
and pro-life
really is it's a it's always been known
as a political choice it's a tough
choice it's a but you're saying most
likely that group doesn't doesn't come
to be yeah so i mean i know of several
anecdotes where someone came out as
pro-life and then their team just
abandoned them and started just
ostracizing them
and there have been events where planned
parenthood and some more pro-choice
things were advertising
in some event
and someone said hey you know either
let's show both sides or let's take
politics out of the workplace and
they're just you know no don't don't
talk to us so there's definitely an
asymmetry there yeah i'm curious because
i've mentioned a little bit lately that
with all the stuff going on with
monetization on youtube
um
it's hard to feel when i've had the
limited contact i've been able to get
with google people it's hard to tell who
knows what or where the buck stops we'll
escalate this we'll you know send
somebody just submit another form for
this do you think that google as an
entity has almost become too big it's
become that 1984 monster
that that the bones of it it's sort of
crumbling under its own bones because it
was abandoning biology in the name of
biology or science or reason whatever
you want to use there in the name of
social justice
yeah i think definitely there's a lot of
disadvantages to becoming too big
especially you know nothing like this
would have ever happened if it was just
a 100 person company because people
would know me and they would know that
i'm not some crazy bigot and if they
disagreed they would just come and talk
to me rather than write some public
messages of how i'm a nazi and we should
all punch him you know
so
yeah and there's a lot of
miscommunication and just
people not knowing what's happening at
google there's you know it's common
where we have multiple
chat apps and stuff it's just
not really some coordinated actions yeah
it's so interesting because the idea
that they fired you
even if let's go on their side for a
second let's say that they figured out
whatever it is there's some loophole
that they've got legit
caused to fire you it's almost like that
then makes you stronger strengthens the
ideas that they don't want strengthened
as opposed to they could have just given
you a silent death you know what i mean
like they could have been like this guy
wrote this thing they let the 24-hour
news cycle spin out and then they slowly
just degrade your position or stop
giving you things and eventually most
likely you leave right you just leave on
your own accord and that's that
yeah there have been multiple cases
where that happened where they just
uh you know they
try to hurt them they put them on
probation
and they just make life as harmful as or
just
as
bad as possible for these people
and that's what usually happens but
i think it was just too much of a pr
issue for them yeah so you had a great
tweet a couple days ago which was that
if we have desensitivity training
then shouldn't we have uh sensitivity
wait
sorry sorry
if we have sensitivity training then
shouldn't we have desensitivity training
for those who are ego easily triggered
right do you want to say that better
than i just said it just to be clear did
i get a point across there
yeah i it was mostly you know we have so
much training about these
microaggressions and oh someone might
find that random thing offensive
and so it just keeps pushing the line of
what we can't say
and there's never any pushback on the
other side and
you know i think yeah there are
definitely some people at google that
are socially awkward and need to be told
that no it's not right to be saying some
of the things that you're saying
but we also need to be telling some
people like come on just calm down
there just look at what their intention
was
and don't get so upset about this
yeah
because jokes are now becoming dangerous
and it's sort of like you know when bill
maher said the n-word on his show
whatever you might think of saying that
specific word i don't think anyone in
their right mind think bill maher is a
racist and suddenly i literally saw
comedians that i know calling for him to
be fired over a word which is sort of an
odd position to be uh to be put in um
right so we've got biology we've got
your
sort of we're caught up on on where you
are at now um do you sense that because
of this that google is going to do
any sort of introspection or any sort of
reevaluating of these policies i really
thought that they would but
at least according to my friends that
are still working there
they've only doubled down on the
diversity efforts and haven't really
addressed any of the political
discrimination
and you know we've brought up these
black lists that people had before these
black lists where uh people will just
have spreadsheets of names
where
these are people that pretty much are
just conservatives or think differently
and they try to sabotage their work or
just don't work for them at all so so
what does that actually mean
like sabotage their work are you talking
about public people who are creating
using google services are you talking
about employees employees within google
they'll
uh so there's so many interdependencies
between projects
that
i will often have to depend on someone
to help me but if i'm on this blacklist
they'll just ignore my email
and you know if i ask them for a
promotion or a peer review for a
performance review then they'll just
give me a bad review
and then once i do get fired because i'm
treated so badly i won't be able to find
work at another company because they
share these blacklists
okay so that i mean that's incredible
yeah i think that's quite revelatory and
incredible and and obviously evil and
insidious and all of that stuff do you
think then
um i hope you have an answer for this
but i know this is this is a tough one
that those lists exist for the creators
too and the people that are using google
services because i don't have to tell
you the i mean for getting monetization
aside the amount of people who generally
are center to even a little bit right to
you can go as far and then you can go
all the way to alex jones but all of
those that people that group that are
out of the mainstream think that feel
like the algorithm's screwing them the
monetization screwing them the
subscriber growth the screening all that
stuff do you have any evidence that any
of that is real so i i don't know if
they just have you know your name in
some random file
but
they
there's other ways for some of these
same things to be happening where they
look for offensive videos and according
to them it's these central or right-wing
videos that are offensive and they never
look at the other side
because they're on the left and
so
it's
through their own political bias and
they may not even be trying to directly
target people but
they just find all of these things and
then they actually feel like
removing these videos or demonetizing
them is the good thing to do
because
you know if i disagree with you
you must be misinformed or evil and so
you're either evil or you're telling
people wrong things and
either way you should just stop doing
that yeah i mentioned to you right
before we started and this is why i'm
doing tucker tonight i mean the amount
of stuff that they've demonetized from
us i'm sorry for my own hershey ali who
i think is one of the greatest human
rights activists on the face of the
earth to then plenty of conservatives of
course ben shapiro and larry elder and
dennis prager uh but then also atheists
like michael shermer comedians michael e
and black and uh and a host of other
people that i think that it's not
censorship that's what i want people to
understand that that in and of itself is
not censorship but if they are screwing
with the algorithm to not allow our
videos to get out now i don't have
evidence of that but at some point when
you take all of these pieces together
you know extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence as carl sagan
said
but you start having to go down that
rabbit hole here right
yeah and
it's
i think a lot of this is also just
multiple teams that google may be doing
the same thing and they may not even
understand some of these algorithms
because you just give them training data
and then
it gives you output
so it they don't really understand this
neural net or like what's happening
within it
and so it it'll be really hard for even
if the government does
uh try to prosecute them to show that
there's explicit bias within the
algorithms and which is so ironic
because for me as a classical liberal
even with some obvious libertarian
leanings i don't really want the
government right to come in and tell
google what to do but i do think there's
something interesting that it seems to
me google itself as a public company
they have a fiduciary responsibility
they're bored to do what's most
profitable and not necessarily what's
politically correct and i suspect that
they're doing things that probably
aren't but i just don't know and again i
say that as someone i don't want the
government necessarily coming in
although i think there is an interesting
argument to be made that these companies
have now become so big and so important
to how we communicate that they sort of
are like electricity and gas and the
rest of that but that's a that's a whole
other uh topic all together um you know
we got a zillion questions from the
audience um do you think in in just what
we've done here that did we do you think
we missed anything that is really
important before we move on to that
portion huh no we can just move on yeah
we did it we did it all right here's
what we're gonna do i say it every time
we do this that we're gonna take a one
minute break then we end up like a three
minute break we're gonna make this a two
minute break and we're gonna take your
questions on patreon we've got a ton of
them already uh we're gonna also take
questions on uh super chat on youtube i
suspect that this video will not be
monetized uh but c'est la vie uh all
right so hang on give us give us two
minutes just to uh freshen up here we
didn't drink you want to take a sip of
water here let's take a sip of water
all right two minutes and then your
questions with james moore
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right i think we did it two minutes
there we go uh so first off we have a
gajillion questions on patreon here
which i'm glad that my audience is so
receptive to what you're talking about
because i think it's really why people
are supporting me on an alternate
platform right now and helping me do
what i'm doing uh okay so i'll go with
the heavy one first from patreon any
snowden-like info that you can dish out
on google sharing our info with the
government etc
uh
so
at least when the whole scenario thing
was happening they denied a lot of it
but i mean there are cases where the
government does request
personal information
just like a lot of other companies and
google does give it out
and it's about 40 000 of cases per year
or something
and you know one thing that this is
linked to too is maybe
they will only give it out to maybe
right-wing extremists and not left-wing
extremists i don't know
right we just don't know what the answer
is and i guess that also depends on what
the government's going for if it's we
have a more left-leaning government or a
right but well they'll push back on some
of them so maybe they'll push back on
the left-wing extremists oh oh that's
interesting right right okay um james
what alternatives to google products are
superior in function for us users
i mean
bing isn't that bad i don't know if it's
better but
uh
yeah it's hard to say because i do use
mostly google products yeah well that's
the funny thing i think there'll be a
certain amount of questions here like
people want you to either throw google
under the bus or the products under the
bus i suspect you you don't dislike the
products and you liked the company that
you were working for yeah i i don't want
to hurt google i just want to make
google better yeah
it's so that i mean that's exactly how i
feel about youtube i'm not trying i want
youtube i want the platform that i'm on
to be the best it can be i want this
thing to grow so we can grow you know
but here we are okay we'll do a couple
of super chats here uh well this isn't
even a question but it's just something
nice uh thanks for having the courage to
say something james to everyone else if
you see something unethical taking place
where you work do something say
something the cost of saying silent is
incalculable do you have any regrets
about doing just that
i it's hard to really regret things
because i hope at least the world will
be better because i mean google is a
huge place and it's going to be our
future
so
these are huge issues that we need to
solve
so you're sort of like uh what's his
name that was going after skynet that
terminator um oh yeah oh my god what's
his name i'm blanking everyone in the
comment section uh john
connor john connor it was john connor
yeah all right there you go um let's see
uh
we'll go back to patreon uh in the time
since releasing your memo have any of
the resulting discussions made him made
you change your mind or rethink any of
the conclusions or even at the way in
which you outline your thoughts that's a
great question
i i've definitely
had many discussions with people some
that disagreed with me
i haven't
really differed on some of the core
things
maybe there were some nuances
but
i
some things like there may not be
explicit sexism happening but
there's just you know male typical
behavior which men are just
uh prone and trained to do throughout
their childhood that is what's rewarded
in the workplace sometimes and that may
be an issue that we need to solve but
it's not
this explicit sexism of you're a woman
you can't do this it's just
you know a lot of competitive
competition and you know talking over
people is
rewarded in some ways and that hurts a
lot of people both boys and
uh girls that aren't as assertive right
but in and of itself that generally
happens more to women right right
because women are less assertive which
is what cause of biological reasons is
is your basic argument yeah and so i
would say that you know the
these are
uh
they may be predisposed to be a certain
way on average but it's not like we
can't
change that in some ways
and you know you could obviously train
your kid to be a certain way
and culture has some effects but
you know how much do we want to really
social engineer things you know right
well it's also like when they'll talk
about well men do a lot of business
dealings while playing golf and not
enough women play golf well you can't
force women to play golf i'm all for
women playing golf if they want to play
golf and i don't think they should be
excluded if they want to play golf but
you can't force them nor would i want a
man to be forced to do whatever women
are doing what are women doing let me
see if i get in some trouble here what
do the women do like golf men for gaffa
let it go uh i at least what i heard was
you know going to nail salon going to
the nail salon naturally all right now
we know it's going to be clipped uh can
james elaborate on the underground
conservative groups that you mentioned
with rogan being myself in the computing
industry that sounds terrifying so you
were on joe rogan yesterday i didn't
even realize it unfortunately so i
haven't seen it yet um but i but i love
joe he's become a major ally in in this
space and for helping you know free
thinkers and things like that so what
was this about underground conservative
groups yeah so there's some groups
within multiple companies that you know
of conservatives that feel alienated by
the dominant culture
and they're not really connected at the
moment because
there's so much there's so many people
that want to infiltrate them
and you know record oh yeah this person
said this one thing that could be
construed to be racist and then get all
those people fired or something
and so it it's really a tricky thing
that i don't want to disclose too much
of because of some of these issues okay
i think that's fair uh uh super chat as
a guy studying i.t who also leans
conservative libertarian i feel as if
everyone else in the field leans far
left
in your experience is that true
yeah
far left or libertarian
because libertarian is this very logical
type
but they often just
and they agree with a lot of the social
issues of just being you know socially
liberal but if you're socially
conservative then you'll get ostracized
often
i think at least for some of these
people working for a smaller company
is maybe the better thing to do now that
that's an interesting piece of this that
at the end of the day if you want to
have as much autonomy over yourself and
your thoughts on all of those things
that may be working at one of these
giant monsters who are trying to appease
it to everybody is just not the way to
do it yeah or a piece to the mob really
right the mob exactly well said uh do
the strongest political activists have
any special access to our information
are they mostly in lower positions in
the company i think this is particularly
interesting because it gets to something
that we talked about before where even
when i've had discussions with youtube
people i don't think that anyone
necessarily is outright lying to me but
how do how can we figure out where
things are going up the chain or where
the final decisions are or where
that subtle thing that could happen in
the algorithm is happening or any of
that is there any way to decipher any of
that stuff at least for outsiders no
there's no real way of figuring out yeah
what do you mean outsiders well just
people that aren't employees
oh okay so someone probably knows
something that you probably don't know
yeah
there's
definitely some people that know certain
things
and
but it's pretty distributed throughout
the company right because i would guess
i mean just by if you were a smart
company up to bad [ __ ] and you wanted to
slowly harm certain people on an
algorithm well you wouldn't tell the
people who talk to the creators about
what you're doing yeah so the the people
who are talking to them aren't it's like
plausible deniability right they're
going oh no no we don't do anything and
they think they're being honest but the
guys higher up are going yeah we're
tightening the the screws on the
algorithm so we know that this stuff
isn't going to get out yeah there's a
lot of legal things that they the pr
people or anyone that discusses it with
external people they can't really
discuss it all right and by the way i
asked the youtube people to send me a
representative i said anyone i mean you
wanna send me a janitor just give me
somebody that works in that building and
of course i got declined um
how bad do you think this echo chamber
problem is in other companies or
business spheres like engineering
business legal etc do you think there's
something unique to the uh silicon
valley stuff
yeah i think
it's probably happens elsewhere but it
is pretty bad in silicon valley
particularly because there are so many
of the same tech companies in a small
area
and they have so much money and they do
they just throw it out to
causes that they believe in
and they feel so guilty because
you know they're only 20 women
that it that pushes a lot of these uh
issues
uh so we sort of hit on this one but but
maybe we can get more your feelings on
this do you think it makes sense to
treat monopolies more like we treat
government institutions that is hold
them accountable so they don't engage in
practices that google seems to be
engaging how about a market share tax to
prevent great concentration of power
instead of punishing success direct
directly so the basic crux of the
question is when does is there a time
that the government sort of has to step
in here and i know you have obviously
some libertarian leanings probably don't
really want that but are we getting to
like some point now where this may be
out of control in a way that somebody
has to step in
yeah
because i definitely have the leanings
of i don't want the government to be
regulating them at all
and i don't know if we have examples of
them actually regulating
your websites
because it's much easier for someone to
just go to a different website
but
they have been getting a little too big
in some ways and europe has fought back
i don't know if uh the us will fight
back right i mean and then even when you
say that the idea of the government now
regulating these things i don't like
that but what i would want is more
competition and i guess the inherent
problem is that maybe they really are
monopoly in a certain way you could take
10 of the richest people on earth and if
they had to create a youtube alternative
uh they still may not have enough money
because of what they're dealing against
um
let's see search for something about
james on google and they disable the
autocomplete for your name oh really
really some 1984 stuff going on there
how about that one for you
i get so really all right that was your
answer
they definitely looked at what the
autocompletes were
and
maybe they didn't like what they were i
don't know if anyone saw what they were
before well i would suspect if they're
not letting it load that it probably was
people saying is right
isn't a nazi uh not a white supremacist
etc
um we've sort of hit this already but do
you intend on staying in public for long
i'm sure the drama is addicting i mean
there's something to be said about that
just that you know people know who you
are now that's pretty cool you get a lot
of traction on twitter and all that
stuff um
hey
there are
nice things of you know being recognized
on the street
and
you know having
random followers on twitter
but
it's definitely draining and it's not
my innate personality so
i'm still trying to figure out what's
best for me yeah you don't strike me as
much of a publicity [ __ ] to be honest
with you um
james was of course aware of the pc
climate and culture and why did he write
the memo what did what did you think
would happen that's sort of interesting
because
did you think there was a chance knowing
everything you know about all this stuff
did you think there was a chance that it
was going to get to the diversity people
and they'd be like well you know
page six he actually kind of makes a
point it's reverse of everything we've
ever said here and promoted and that
they were going to do anything i mean
did you think that that maybe it would
get through so i really thought that
they would at least look at it and think
about it rationally because that's what
we do for everything else at google you
know you see a problem
and then you write a document
to solve it and then people look at it
make comments and something is done
so we're really big into this
type of you know objective open exchange
of ideas but apparently not for this
and you know i actually list you know 10
different suggestions that we should do
hopefully they'll they're actually
looking at that but i don't know all
right don't hold your breath
uh okay back to super chat um
let's see
uh you and others should form a group
similar to fire the foundation for
individual rights and education but for
tech companies thoughts i love this
question because one of the things that
i actually meant to ask you is all these
organizations eric weinstein who i know
you've now met
he has said to me a few times that what
these companies need is that it's one
thing okay you want to have a diversity
group and make sure there's equal
opportunity for everyone that's great
but what you also need is a free speech
group or a free expression group so
these things sort of work in parallel
together to make sure that the diversity
group isn't stepping on freedom of
expression or the ability for someone
with a
contrarian opinion to say anything do
you think that's a good idea yeah i
definitely think that we should be
looking more into this and i've been
talking to the header docs academy oh
great great where they look a lot about
you know what universities can people
freely exchange ideas and there's a lot
of interest from companies to apply that
same
idea to
their workplace
so because you know hr is not realizing
that hey a lot of people agree with this
and they feel alienated i wasn't even
aware of that
you know maybe we should do something
yeah i'm curious this isn't on here but
we're just bringing it back to the
modernization one more second because
it's just rattling in my head right now
when you hear about this stuff related
to the monetization do you actually
think that the companies that are
selling ads
uh
to google
uh that are that are putting their ads
out there that they really don't want
their ads on all this stuff or do you
think that this is ideological or is it
combination of both
yeah it's hard to say i think
there's some
a few very loud voices
saying oh yeah these these videos are
horrible
and that may create bad publicity for
disney or something if they put their
ads there but
i
i at least hoping that
we won't be dictated by just you know
the one really loud voice
yeah um
this is interesting uh what do you think
about the role of collective bargaining
unions etc and uh oh and at wheel
employment in tech
i i think
definitely you know i'm pretty
libertarian but i think that there are
cases for
um
some of these collective bargainings and
just
you know giving more power to employees
because
there is a huge asymmetry in power
between employees and employer it's not
as much of a
free market type thing that we would
like to see
and you know i i do agree that
uh you know even at will doesn't mean
that they can just fire you for no
reason at all and there are some cases
in the national labor relations board
right now where
people have
you know
this is a bad example but they said the
n word to someone and then they got
fired and that's actually against the
law you can't fire someone for doing
that
which is you know maybe they should be
able to but there are limits to what
people can fire you for
super chat if if at t listens to your
calls and disconnected your phone when
you said the wrong thing we would be up
in arms the fcc should remove google's
common carrier status because they
monitor and filter traffic
i mean i think we've sort of danced
around do you have anything any other
thoughts on that i mean it's that i mean
this is a tough spot for for a
libertarian i think
yeah
it's getting to a point where
you know power is being accumulated in
just a few key players and at some point
we're really going to have to
fight back against that because too much
power whether it's in the government's
hand or a private company isn't good for
the general public
uh this is interesting from super chat i
found that my political views changed
completely when i was on antidepressant
are you aware of any studies linking far
left political views and antidepressants
that would be fascinating like
fascinating fascinating you got anything
on that so there are
some
connections between
you know some drug use and political
orientation so psychedelics for example
can increase your openness long term
and openness is related to progressive
or left so
you know that was potentially one of the
reasons they actually um
banned psychedelics was that it actually
changed how you voted
but
i i don't know about antidepressants
specifically okay uh keep up the good
work dave and james if james wants to
come up to toronto and make 15 an hour
he's got a job waiting for him all right
we got you a job uh also dave you
pronounce the word because strange
because how do you say because because
because because because i'm from long
island suck it up all right a question
for both of you does uh
does having youtube red help the content
creators i watch with demonetization or
does the money go straight to google
thanks love the show dave uh i'll let
you answer that one first so you don't
know so well i know that when they look
at our monetization which is quite
horrific these days when i look at the
back end we see a certain amount just
from regular ad plays and that sort of
thing and then we see another number for
youtube red
i have no idea what that how that number
is broken down or anything like that
that's all i know but i know that yes if
you have youtube red and you watch this
that we're getting some all right
that's all i know yeah i would at least
hope that they don't give you a smaller
percent than normal
but they may just be right but but
do you want to finish that sentence no i
think
no one really knows besides them yeah
um after seeing the google attempt to
disable jordan peterson's account how
soon do you think google will begin
cutting off access to average users with
these harmful opinions
i mean hopefully they saw how much bad
pr
the whole jordan peterson thing was for
them that they'll stop doing this type
of stuff do we know what happened there
i mean i remember the day that it
happened but do we know what
specifically happened that caused that
whole thing so they claimed that there
was some automated anti-spam detection
and
you know maybe that was and there were
some contradictions in the story where
they said that there was some human
looking at it but then later they said
that there was no human looking at it i
mean it just sounds like such anti-spam
protections i mean the guy is one of the
most brilliant professors and i think
preeminent thinkers we have literally in
the world right now the idea that that's
the way these things would be treated is
just uh is just ridiculous um
what about putting programs like this on
twitch denying google traffic and income
i would like to see them punished for
this action i mean
people are trying to figure out some
other avenues do you have an alternate
avenue for any well i guess we asked you
about the services before
anything else we don't know about i mean
there's twitch dailymotion vimeo those
are all other
video hosting sites they're just much
smaller than youtube
um
let's see there's a lot about you know
that there's a lot of these people that
are saying that they're conservative or
libertarian that just feel that they're
they're afraid to talk about things
um
in some ways are you relieved not to
work for a company that is so hell-bent
on pushing their agenda because you
don't you strike me as actually kind of
at peace with everything like
you don't i mean i can tell you're
you're in it
but
do you feel a certain sense of peace in
this craziness i i try to you know i
meditate and i
i try to
just not regret things in general
but
you know i i really wanted to change
google from the inside rather than what
i'm doing right now
you would rather yeah so you would have
rather had this thing just everything
being equal you would just go back and
have had them listen to some of this
stuff and
maybe make it better
james i interned at google in la this
summer and watched this debacle unfold
from the inside do you think the unique
culture inside google meme memejen
especially reinforces
progressive dogma by design or does it
arise naturally uh also did you write an
epitaph it wasn't visible when i last
checked
so yeah epitaph is something that you
can write and
so people can contact you after you
leave and you can give some reasons why
you left or something oh i thought it
was much darker than that somehow
i i didn't write one because so when
they called me and said oh you're fired
they shut off my access completely man
just like that yeah have you ever been
in any trouble with google before no had
even one comment sent to hr had anyone
in hr ever said your work is not good
you're the way you're treating women or
any other employee or anything no i had
just gotten promoted so i i got the like
highest performance review possible and
so it it definitely wasn't performance
related
oh but there was a first part of that
yeah so the first part being do you
think that the unique culture inside
google meme gen especially reinforces
progressivism by design or does it arise
naturally
there's
it's hard to say i i think
a platform like ningen is only going to
push these mob mentalities and virtue
signaling and the head of meme gen
is was actually very active in trying to
attack mine at some point he so this was
just a google doc he uh suggested to
just delete it all which would do a
strikethrough all through all the words
and that was just left there for a while
people couldn't read it
like people that high up in the company
shouldn't be doing stuff like that right
right
okay
just to remind everyone where where are
you you're over there uh just to remind
everybody we're taking questions on
patreon and on super chat with we're
with james damore uh for a little longer
uh super chat dave welcome back wanted
to say that we i at least donate to you
because you're using our money so well
so it's a two-way appreciation thank you
for that for my question can james
explain more context around memos and
their usual impact internally that's
interesting
yeah so
and this was just a google doc it wasn't
an email that i just sent out
and uh
so
wait can you just take that a little
further because i think there's a
certain amount of people again that
think you blasted this publicly you went
to
whoever was gonna you know get it to the
most eyeballs and all that but that is
simply not what you did right as we
explained earlier yeah it was just a
google deck that i shared with some
people and then i
uh put it on the skeptics list and was
like oh what do you think about you know
my views of google's ideology idol
ideological echo chamber
am i on to something or am i in my own
echo chamber
so yeah there's a lot of documents at
google that you know try to
fix issues in the culture
and
i actually you know modeled this after
some of the other ones that i saw
um i don't know if you know the answer
to this one super chat will you join the
people of kekistan and provide your
skills to create an algorithmic weapon
to surpass metal
uh i guess i just say you'll think about
it oh think about it
um should google's machine learning
algorithms be made open source that's
really interesting
possibly i it's part of their
intellectual property and that's how
they have an advantage over other
competitors so it's
it's hard to say what they really should
do fair
um
let's see
uh
the department of labor is trying to
cook up a discriminate rate
discrimination against women case
against google their only problem is
that they don't have evidence to support
the case so arguably this case was
caused in large part by government
over-regulation
because i've been a little out of the
loop the last little bit i haven't heard
about this do you know anything about
that yeah there's uh some case of
they're saying that there's a pay
disparity between men and women and all
i know is that the internal reports that
they've been doing for like four years
now have shown that
there is no gender disparity once you
control for a performance which the
external uh
you know uh government agency doesn't
really know about our performance
reviews and anything they just know the
aggregate statistics
so
i don't think they'll really find
anything but
right especially since it's not like
individual managers even get to choose
oh you get to pay get paid this much or
not it's all by committee and they you
know tried to do this controlled by
gender stuff
uh
quote do no evil end quote used to be
google's motto how does james feel that
google in and alphabet as a whole are
doing in general and living up to their
former motto yeah so i i think that they
still believe in the uh do no evil don't
be evil thing but
it's that
the definition of evil
has changed and they started mandating
it both internally and externally so
it's now just if we don't agree with you
then you're evil you know we don't like
your youtube uh thing so we're going to
censor it or demonetize it
so there is some evil by my definition
of evil yeah uh welcome back back dave
it looks like a month off duty is some
good i have libertarian leanings but
government still has a place in some
areas does it not the key is to not have
too much power in one place in my
opinion we've discussed this already a
couple of times and i think
that's why this story is so interesting
to me too because it puts our own
beliefs and biases up for the challenge
now right we see them you see a major
problem with a company that again that
you like that you wish this would have
helped you don't want the government to
come in and take too much power and it's
a great argument to have over over all
that stuff do you have any other
thoughts on that well i'll answer it
quickly yeah no i think we've already
covered that okay
um
now we're really going to put you on the
spot super chat uh how has james
newfound infamy affected his love life
are the liberty-minded ladies storming
the d'amore castle
uh yeah so
my girlfriend uh she
sort of disagreed on some things but
it's more that she really doesn't want
this to be true that there is some sort
of political bias affecting how we're
seeing these issues
uh i mean we've grown stronger because
of this you know struggles sometimes
bring people together
i mean i have gotten random messages
from women that
seem to like me but
i haven't really bit on that at all
enough yeah well for a crazy misogynist
girlfriend's stuck with you and you're
getting you're hearing from other women
all right um
let's see
um
[Music]
oh this is interesting in your
experience at google do the witch
hunters use their colleagues social
media content against them should young
conservatives and libertarians in tech
stay away from social media altogether i
get this type of question a lot related
to college kids when i go to schools and
they'll say well can i talk about this
now i want to get good grades i don't
want my professor you know fighting
against me or anything like that yeah i
think it can definitely hurt you if you
post conservative or
just other
uh types of things on social media and
you know we've even seen i think pax
dickinson wrote some things on twitter
and then he got fired from the cto
position
so
what you say in social media
can be used against you by these
social justice warriors yeah uh super
chat plus one for rational and
respectful dialogue
real news all right
real news something's real i can't
believe it
um
the the blacklist this is super chat are
designed to bully that is disrespect at
work by the bullies
the nazis did the same thing all right
let's put the word nazi aside because
you're being called a nazi which is
obviously idiotic um but these the idea
of these lists
these secret or it sounds like they're
not even that secret right i mean these
are yeah people admit to having them
yeah how dangerous do you think that is
i suspect quite because you were
probably on or you're probably on every
single one of them
yeah they're pretty dangerous and just
the fact that it's socially acceptable
to admit that you have these and you
openly pretty much hate certain people
it's
that's a slippery slope yeah is there
any evidence that google conservatives
secretly have lists of lefties that they
won't work with is there any evidence of
those lists existing i have to ask
i i don't really know i
i think that they're so
angry at just the idea of these
blacklists and they see the harm that
it's causing
but there may be some people that you
know see the tactics used by the other
side and want to use them too
um our decentralized platforms like
yours.org uh
org library steam and others the future
of media and do you have any interest in
cryptocurrencies like bitcoin
i think yeah they definitely have
potential and the more that people see
centralized power can lead to some
negative consequences the bigger they
will come become what about bitcoin and
what's the new one arithium erythema
yeah beryllium what the hell is it i
know they were mining it on avatar
what's that one
uh the new one arithium oh i don't know
how ethereum i think it's ethereum or
something yeah what do you make of
cryptocurrency in general
um
they have potential but
it's really hard to say
and there's a lot of disputes even
within the bitcoin community on exactly
how it should be implemented and that's
why we're seeing multiple of them now
so it's pretty risky but people have
made a lot of money uh betting on them
so yeah i have like two bitcoin i'm just
kind of leaving them there and we'll see
what happens it's like twelve thousand
dollars or something is that twelve
thousand dollars yeah it's
it's really grown don't worry i'm losing
enough on youtube modernization that it
probably all evens itself out uh from
patreon do you think there's any chance
for a pendulum shift back towards the
center in tech and large companies
generally where these issues can be
reasonably debated and discussed without
the immediate social prize status and
firings or have things gone so far past
that point that the only viable
alternative is for new companies to be
created again we've sort of hit on this
but that's interesting like do you think
there's a chance we could even put
google aside for this one that that this
story the lesson of this story might
help in ways that we can't see right now
yeah
i think if there's a chance just because
you know even though there's the
political bias and just natural biases
that are causing some of this there's
also just the financial incentive that
they may have where they see if they
don't
you know tow the party line that they'll
get attacked
but
if there's also financial incentives to
not
you know have these blacklists and
fire anyone that disagrees then that'll
at least moderate them in some ways
uh any idea of how far google is willing
to go to silence viewpoints it doesn't
agree with well we know they fire people
you got anything else i
yeah they're
they'll uh they'll do some certain
things i mean they'll remove ads from
certain websites they'll remove youtube
videos
they may push results far from google
search results
i i don't know the
exact extent that they'll go though yeah
well it's interesting because i can see
you're you're really trying not to throw
them under the bus you're being careful
with your words not to say anything
that's untrue
and yet you're sort of given a little
bit of like uh you're leaving some
crumbs for some of the path to be found
and i think that's what people people
are trying to figure out here
which i think is i think it's a credit
to you
um let's see i don't think this is a
cause for government intervention i
think this is a symptom of government
interference in society in general and
supporting social justice do you agree
that's an interesting
take yeah and that can be uh
i can definitely be the case because as
i was saying before you know they've
there's a lot of people suing for these
social justice causes
and uh at least i've heard anecdotes of
these activists
that will blackmail companies say hire
us for these diversity programs or we'll
sue you
and so they're sort of pushing it and
it's only because they could sue and get
the government involved
that they're able to push this agenda
yeah and if people want to know how
bananas this whole thing is i mentioned
to you right before we started i got an
email from a friend of mine who's a
somewhat public person who will not be
named right this moment because i don't
think he wants to go public with this
stuff who's in hollywood in a and he's a
straight white man
and basically has been told by almost
everyone in the industry we're not going
to hire you anymore like they're flat
out saying it to him at this point and
this is a guy who has a pretty great
resume
and is and is just screwed because of
this lunacy uh all right super chat
great episode dave shout out to the new
subreddit called stop being evil it's
dedicated to exposing google's
censorship and other creepy behavior i
guess have you seen this subreddit yet
oh yeah someone yesterday on my
subreddit actually uh oh you have your
own subreddit is that where you did the
the original write again i was off the
grid when you did this uh yeah i did an
ama on my subreddit i didn't really know
how to do it so i i figured i could do
it on this one right because uh there
were some you know right wing people
that wanted me to do it on there and
i i didn't want it to be political
really i just wanted to be sort of
neutral
but you know you should come over
they're pretty friendly yeah i i i saw
your subreddit and they they seemed
sort of angry i don't know well i don't
even want to get into that
they were that wasn't my
my own thing right
yeah it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
it seems that the best way to
decentralize the power of large
companies such as google could be
accomplished by the removal of patent
thoughts this is another interesting one
for for a libertarian yeah i mean
patents can definitely
cause the centralization of power
because you know you only just gain more
and more power as you gain these patents
and they're used as tools by the
extremely wealthy companies to attack
competitors
so it creates a barrier to entry
definitely
uh i love this question and i can't
believe i didn't ask it what top level
companies if any are doing things right
in terms of diversity opinion do you see
some companies doing it right because
i'll promote the hell out of them and
i'll try to work with them and i'll try
to do stuff with them if so
i there's some companies that have
talked to me and it seems like they're
doing the right thing but
i don't know if
i should uh make them public just
because
they talk to me in private right which
think how sort of unfortunate that is
but maybe you could tell me privately
after i'll keep it between us but but
hopefully that that shows a little see
that's the thing what this what this
uh accusation of nazi all right nonsense
says so they a company has to privately
go to you now you have an interesting
opportunity to help promote them but you
don't even know if they want that help
from you or from me or whoever and
that's such a it's such a shitty
situation
it's interesting to hear james keep
using we
to refer to google being in
involuntarily separated from a company
you care about is difficult to get past
i think that's pretty creative
it's still i feel like they're part of
my family or i'm part of their family
but
i i definitely see myself saying we
allowed to i believe this is what they
call the black sheep of the family
with the amount of informational
information that google manages do you
think that they or some automated
process could attempt some form of
subtle manipulation like generating echo
chambers shadow banding and even some
form of really subtle blackmail i think
your answer to is yes to this that we
just kind of don't know yeah although i
i don't know if they're so far as you
know targeting specific users and
deciding oh this is someone that we
don't like therefore we're going to show
them weird stuff
but you know
a lot of social networks try to find
what your preferences are just
algorithmically and will show you things
that you like so it's not unique to
youtube for example to show you videos
that you like you know
facebook is also creating its own echo
chamber
so it's a problem in general fair enough
uh you mentioned the other day that the
google image search ads are technically
sexist
do you know of anything else similar in
google slash youtube search and ads can
can you explain that further
i i don't remember saying that the ads
were sexist i mean i think
we or do you know what this person's
referring to i didn't hear it so i and
they're they're definitely
you know we look at demographics of the
user and we try to infer that and we use
that to maybe show them different ads
so in that way it might be sexist and we
also look at different companies like
instagram and pinterest which were
competitors to image search and we saw
hey the majority of those users are
women
and the reason was that women are more
open to aesthetics which is another
thing that i mentioned
and
so we definitely use some of these
things when we're designing products but
we may not be able or we may not be so
open about discussing them in our
diversity programs this is a total
sidebar it's not on here but as you know
i was just off the grid for a month and
i truly i felt like a million bucks i
thought i cleared my mind in so many
ways i felt my train of thought was
better my attention span was better i
was more attentive to people and my dog
um just as a general thing like do you
feel we're just too inundated with this
stuff at this point like as humans and
what our brains have evolved to be what
they biologically are you think you're
staring at this thing today might be a
problem
yeah i think we're definitely too
addicted to
being connected
and more just person-to-person
interactions and maybe interacting with
nature
can definitely improve your general
happiness
fair enough all right i'm going to keep
keep doing work in the yard out there um
okay we did that one uh i have people
telling me that enforcing immigration
laws is racist i don't understand that
level of delusion the left seems to have
lost its mind how can i begin
deprogramming the religion of the left
so obviously this is going to my real
house i talk about this a lot what do
you think is a tactic if you see someone
that's buying all of this stuff
yeah it's really hard i think
some of jonathan heights work is really
good in explaining the ideology behind
the left and right and showing that
you know they disagree but it's not
because conservatives are just racists
sexist bigots it's they have different
morals that they're operating on
and
those cause them to see issues
differently
and at least you know showing that you
have a different point of view
and it's not just a bigoted point of
view that there's morals of you know
having a law and order or something like
that
is
not necessarily bigoted
right
um
well i think we already got this but do
you have any insight into what's driving
the demonetization of so many youtube
videos now or did you work in a
completely separate area of google so we
could just answer that in the context of
your work didn't as a people here
software engineer
what in the world does that even mean at
a place like google there's a gajillion
products yeah so i was a coder for image
and video search
and so we interacted with youtube
actually and i
interned at youtube so i interacted with
them a little bit and
and you know there were company-wide
meetings so everyone at google knew some
aspects of it
i
their demonetization
thing i think that really ramped up in
the controversy last year where there
were some advertisers that were just
angry about
particular videos having their ads so
that was the excuse for them to start
doing a lot of this demonetization but
i don't know how much of it is a
rational response to that and how much
of it is just ideologically driven at
this point do you think they were
waiting for an excuse that even though
they knew it was going to hurt the
bottom line which as i said before it
could be an issue with shareholders uh
you know in terms of stock you think
they were just waiting in a way like
they got the call from whoever those i
think at t or whoever call you know
canceled the bulk ads and they were like
oh we're losing money but yay because we
can finally move on this ideological
thing that we care about yeah it's
possible and you know you mentioned that
this is hurting their bottom line but
they've actually stated when they went
public that we'll do certain things that
we see as right but will hurt our bottom
line so they're definitely open to
stuff like that that's interesting
listen i don't have enough information
on what
as i've said the fiduciary
responsibility of a company is to its
shareholders but i think there's some
there's just something interesting to
explore there it is very obvious that
that is not what i am an expert in
um
all right
uh
in your opinion should google as a
company be split up similar to standard
oil was split up in the early 20th
century i think we've kind of bounced
around that if you've got anything else
let me know
oh have you done do you know about the
reasoning behind altering the search
results for
american inventors the image results are
all people of color and women and i
don't recognize 90 percent of them and
benjamin franklin shows up only on the
first few pages so a bunch of people
have sent this to me is it american
inventors is that the phrase yeah if you
just search american inventors when
you're within america
then it shows
just a lot of these minority inter uh
inventors and not some of the more
famous ones even though if you do the
same search in a different country or
sometimes in a different language it'll
show some of the more famous ones uh i
think someone does that mean i mean
really now so give me some insight how
in the world does that happen no one has
a problem with my not no one but i
certainly don't have a problem and the
average person and 99 of americans don't
have a problem
uh with a minority inventor or a uh or a
female inventor but if you're searching
inventors you want to know who the big
shots are in this case i guess most of
them happen to be white at least
you know within the context of american
whatever
so what is this yeah i think a lot of it
just is someone complained
about oh this wasn't diverse enough and
therefore we need to change it
and so they fiddled with it a little bit
and now it's how it is so it's basically
an endless hostage situation i think is
sort of what you described before that
because these words of racist and bigot
have taken such meaning that everyone
then that's about to be subjected to
it'll be like yeah i'll screw with the
algorithm no problem we'll put benjamin
franklin on the 18th page you know what
everyone will forget about him yeah
that's uh that's scary um
all right well i think you've also
answered this but what motivated you to
make such a public position on a heated
topic like this what made you want to be
the test case you're a braver man than i
cheers
i mean i never meant for the document
itself to be public but once it was i
felt like i sort of had a responsibility
to
you know at least show that i'm not some
sort of
nazi white supremacist
and
how did that get part of the link now i
understand it but for the average person
watching this how does that where you
write this and then suddenly you're
being called alt-right and a white
supremacist and all that how do you even
see how they do that trip
yeah i think that they just
there's not really any logic behind it
it's just they want to smear my name
and they
say oh yeah he didn't say this but he
implied it in some way
and
yeah i
they just do it to hurt people in
general of people whose opinions they
disagree with
uh all right you know what i think we'll
do two here two more i think uh you've
been very focused and here and uh
i think i think two more is fair because
i think a lot of you know there's a ton
of support for you obviously here um and
all that stuff so here we go so um
this is the best interview i've seen
with james demour and i've seen them all
terrific job fascinating content okay
thank you as i'll still do two more uh
you have a favorite book or blog that
you might want to send people to or tell
people to read
at least about this blank the blank
slate by stephen pinker was pretty good
mm-hmm
and
i think we're getting them on the show
we've been working on it oh really yeah
that'd be great we're trying we're
trying uh in your opinion do you think
there will be practical
ramifications for not promoting or
hiring based on merit meaning that the
actual google software will be
negatively affected this is a really
complex question but i think it's a good
one
yeah and
definitely that could happen and
especially as things get more and more
complicated within google you get
bigger and bigger systems you need the
best people
so so basically you have these
interdependent systems and if you're not
hiring based on merit alone
that
one system failing starts other systems
to start feeling i mean it really could
be the the collapse of something massive
yeah and you know a lot of what they do
is alienate some of the
really system oriented people like
basically people on the autism spectrum
and those are the people most skilled at
really analyzing these systems and
discovering the rules behind them
and but those are also the people that
don't really understand social
situations as well
and that's who they're punishing with a
lot of this unconscious bias type stuff
which is particularly fascinating
because there's a lot of people that are
on the spectrum in silicon valley right
so it's really this like
it's a double-edged sword but it's also
like a really confounding thing for
these people who just want
to do good work i mean to do the thing
that they're really focused on and
really passionate about
yeah that's something um all right well
i'll ask the last question it will come
from me but thank you guys for
submitting all the questions um
i it's pretty obvious to me you're gonna
you're gonna find a job you're gonna do
well all that good stuff um but i have a
feeling somebody might be out there
watching this right now going out i want
to help this guy um
sure we can send them to your twitter
and all that stuff but you you want to
give any kind of sell a job for somebody
that's that's out there looking for
somebody with your skill set or anything
i'm really putting you on that
yeah
i'm still trying to figure out what
exactly i want to do i if they want to
support the lawsuit there is the
researcher that i have but
uh
yeah i
i'm still personally trying to figure it
out but if anyone really wants to
discuss things just
send me a message and because i'm always
willing to have one-on-one conversations
with anyone
yeah all right well listen if you've
proven anything to me here it's that
you're a humble guy your intentions are
good it seems to me that if you were
provided with evidence that what you
have some of the things that you said
here were wrong or misinformed or
whatever that you'd be happy to continue
that discussion and uh
if you remain a public figure i'd be
happy to do this again and if you don't
i'd be happy to go for coffee or for
lunch and uh and i wish you luck with
everything you're doing yeah thanks all
right well thanks to uh james damore you
can find him on the twitter did you have
the blue check before this whole thing
happened uh yeah i got it before this
one oh no no no no i didn't have twitter
at all before this i still don't really
know how to use it
he wasn't even on twitter before this
people he's got the blue check it's a
and his handle is quite appropriate it's
fired for the number four truth uh so i
thank james and i will be on tucker
carlson tonight probably discussing some
of this stuff uh and discussing the
youtube situation and all that and and
again as i will say to tucker tonight
and it's sort of what james said to me
he was talking about these things
because he wanted the company to be
better that's what i want youtube to be
and more transparent and all that good
stuff so anyway thanks for watching this
and we are live tomorrow oh no we're uh
we were going to do blair white tomorrow
but i believe we are tuesday we're doing
it on tuesday there you go i got a team
back there i'm not making this stuff up
all right thank you guys for watching
[Music]
you